Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this would be my Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 alternate ending deleted scene video
Marvel just revealed a completely different ending
which changes a lot of the future of Marvel's Big
Avengers level crossovers in a lot of the space
based movies as well as a bunch of cool deleted
scenes and details about high evolutionary's past
visits to Earth which they reveal happened during
the 80s so I'll talk about that too suddenly Nick
Fury is getting so much busier with all these
aliens visiting planet Earth back in the 80s and
the 90s if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos and careful
for spoilers from the movie if you haven't seen
it yet because we need to talk about everything
mostly the ending obviously everybody dance
but in the theatrical version of the movie at the
end rocket finally confronts High evolutionary
after spending years running from him avoiding
him as much as possible he's meant to be about
15 years old in the MCU in present day and it
seems like based on his level of development
when he escaped he's been on the run for at
least 10 years or more and with the help of
the rest of the Guardians of the Galaxy they
all tag team him almost kill him with rockets
stopping short of double tapping him with his gun
just to make sure that he's dead Gamora even rips
his face off which they use in the movie to make
him a little more comic book accurate because in
the comics High evolutionary wears a red mask
that covers his entire head mostly to hide the
fact that years of experiments and upgrades that
he'd performed on himself had totally messed his
face up like his face is messed up in the movie
but in the comics the big difference is that he
did that to himself in the movie rocket did that
clawing his face off when he escaped they also
used that in the movie to pay off all the Face-Off
preferences from earlier in the film because his
face literally comes off so as he's lying there
barely alive and faceless rocket decides not to
kill him him both to show him Mercy to show
how much he's grown as a person even though
he's technically a raccoon even though it takes to
the very end of the movie before he realizes that
he really is a raccoon fun fact too he's related
to all those baby raccoons that he actually saved
those are part of the original raccoons that high
evolutionary selected rocket from and they want
to show that Rocket's not the same bitter spiteful
raccoon you meet in the first Guardians movie he's
way more mature he started to process his trauma
at high evolutionary's hands and also the whole
idea is that at this point in the movie after
he destroyed his own creation counter Earth his
own actions obsessing over rocket head led to
the utter destruction of his own ship the loss
of his next level being the race that philavel
Quasar belonged to that he just created in all
the other research and information that he gained
over hundreds of years he's meant to be about 300
years old in the MCU his actions led to the utter
loss of everything he previously owned or created
basically so he was left with nothing not even
his own face so killing him would have been a
mercy so it's almost more hardcore to leave him
alive rocket does leave him alive and in the
theatrical cut we see all the Guardians of the
Galaxy saving philovel's new race of children
all the animals High evolutionary had kept for
experiments taking them to nowhere to live we
see high evolutionaries Cube ship completely
destroyed it finishes blowing up and you never
actually see what happened to his body there
was a lot of speculation about this because
it's a comic book movie you don't see his body it
usually means he survives somehow and here's the
thing Chuckwudi Iwuji himself High evolutionary
himself actually confirmed this big alternate
ending deleted scene in the alternate ending they
filmed a much more obvious looking scene of Drax
carrying the high evolutionaries barely alive
body off of his ship with everyone else of the
animals taking him to Nowhere let me just put it
this way you will be um I'm hoping you see in an
extended version and maybe an alternate ending
you know that we certainly did fill you know I
mean the whole point is that in Marvel unless
you see someone die they haven't necessarily
died and even if they do die what does that mean
in a Multiverse right but the point is that uh
rocket doesn't shoot me they make a point
of saying why don't you kill him and he says
no I'm not going to kill him and you don't
actually see me uh go down with the ship so
and if you look at the theatrical cut at least
the version that's playing in theaters right now
you can actually kind of see Drax carrying him
really tiny and blurry in the background but in
the scene he's super small on frame everything
is exploding all around them there's a bunch of
other characters so it is pretty easy to miss also
there's the idea in the theatrical cut that in the
aftermath the rest of the ending of the movie
where Peter Quill names rocket the new leader
of the Guardians announces he's taking a break for
a hot minute till Avengers Kane Dynasty at least
goes back to Earth and the rest of the Guardians
all go their separate ways in the alternate ending
version of this where they made it more obvious
that high evolutionary survived we would have seen
that much more obvious version of Drax carrying
the high evolutionaries passed out body to nowhere
and possibly a quick scene of him during the
celebration still comatose from his injuries the
same way they give you a little tag scene at the
very end during the dance off like a montage of
all the different characters just to let you know
that oh they're still alive like even Adam Warlock
had a scene where he was watching the other
Guardians had their dance off so the fact that
high evolutionaries survived raises some questions
about his future in the M's see you because he's a
huge character Chuckwudi Iwuji was a fantastic
villain too his performance probably one of the
best villain performances in a Marvel movie in a
long long time so even if they'd actually Perma
killed him like even if it was confirmed that he
had died I still would have loved to see him come
back as a variant in some Future movie but since
this MCU version is technically still alive I'd
love to see him come back in a future space-based
movie or bigger crossovers like bigger Avengers
level movies with him adapting more of his high
evolutionary comic book stories because in the
comics he's actually much more involved in the
big crossover events he winds up working with
the heroes just as much as he winds up playing
the villain in different stories in fact a lot
of those stories James Gunn borrowed from for the
plot of Guardians 3 particularly Adam warlock's
backstory like high evolutionary actually helps
him a lot in his backstory he's the person that
upgraded Adam Warlock and gave him the soul gem
he also worked with the Guardians of the Galaxy
during the annihilation storyline against
annihilus and then later the sequel story
with the return of Ultron I just did a big video
too about an annihilist deleted scene because he
was actually going to be a big character during
the movie at one point it would have been a much
bigger change to the character because obviously
a nihilus is a big Fantastic Four characters
I'll link that video in the description below
because it's actually pretty cool this is Chuckwudi
Iwuji talking about High evolutionaries
Time on Earth during the 80s specifically I
visited your planet many years ago Earth hasn't
been my planet in a long time if people had
wonderful spirit the art and music and literature
were some of the finest in the universe in fact I
just found out that you know reading an interview
he did that the high evolutionary visited Earth
in the 80s I just find that I was like oh that's
I I wouldn't be it wouldn't have been useful to
me playing it at all because my line is just I
visited your planet years ago that's that's all
I need I've been there and seen it so it sounds
like for the movie James Gunn created all this
extra backstory that he didn't wind up telling
the actors too much about during the day just
so they didn't overcloud whatever their scenes
were in present day but is way more stuff that
just didn't make it into that theatrical cut so
you have to imagine High evolutionary with his
advanced technology like he's already hundreds
of years old visiting Earth in the 1980s with
Samuel L Jackson still in his prime still a
young man in Shield Coulson has probably not
quite yet become an agent because during the 90s
he was meant to be like a very green very brand
new agent and even though I don't expect them to
address High evolutionaries Time on Earth during
the secret Invasion series I do think about learn
more about Nick Fury's history with Shield during
the 80s there was a lot going on in the MCU during
that period mostly Howard Stark still incredibly
active because he wasn't killed by Winter Soldier
until the 90s that was also before Janet Van Dien
had been lost in the quantum realm so Hank Pym and
Janet Van Dyne were still very active as Ant-Man
the WASP working with shield and Peggy Carter who
was also still very active at that point just a
much older version of Peggy Carter remember all
the flashback scenes during the Time Heist and
Avengers end game at Camp Lehigh where during
the 70s so high evolutionary on Earth would be
even after that there was another deleted scene
that we learned about with a very naked version
of Gamora a lot of you asking what was she doing
why was she naked in this scene this probably
would have been when they were changing out of
their prison suits after they made it back to
the guardian's new ship the Bowie after they'd
escaped the giant space butthole and it was
probably part of Peter Quill continuing to Pine
for her trying to win her back because at this
point in the movie he still hadn't completely
gotten over that it was until the very end of
the movie when he was like okay I'll see you when
I see you we were a lot of fun and they kind of
both went their separate ways being friends and
it's not necessarily a deleted scene but it's a
bit of the subtext of the movie with James Gunn
and Karen Gillen nebula talking about this so
Karen Gillen in real life actually said that
she feels like nebula now has a crush on Peter
Quill in the last couple years since Avengers
end game but she has no idea how to process
it emotionally just because she's been so shooty
stabby trying to get over her own trauma the same
way that Rocca was getting over his trauma with
high evolutionary nebula just dealing with her
trauma and her backstory with Thanos whatever it
was that you were in love with it sounds more like
knock it off what you never noticed how black
your eyes were they were replaced by my father
as a method of torture he he picked a pretty
set so I think the whole idea is that nebula
is just starting to open herself to those kinds
of emotions and we're not going to see her get
together with Peter Quill or anything like
that like this is just Karen Gillen talking
with James and James Gunn being like you know
what I hadn't completely intended that but I do
kind of believe it so it's more of the subtext
of the character like it's not the actual text
of the movie and this doesn't mean that nebula
is going to get together with Peter Quill or
anything like that it just means that she's
kind of crushing on him a little bit whereas
previously she would have never even considered
that part of herself like it would have been
buried so deeply in her psyche that it would
never been a thing before there were a bunch
of deleted scenes that James Gunn's been posting
of rocket and his friends when he was a child like
Lila there's a child version of Rocket teeth
floor just all scenes of them figuring stuff
out for the movie and he did reveal that at
least two deleted scenes will wind up on the
Blu-ray but he didn't say which ones he's
gonna put on the Blu-ray for the most part
he said there weren't a ton of deleted scenes
from the movie like traditional deleted scenes
and stop
but it sounds like there were a couple really
big ones which I mostly list here in like the
annihilistice in my other video if they reveal
any more deleted scenes of course I'll do videos
for them we'll get the rest of them by the
time they release the Blu-ray later this
year and when they do that when they release
it I'll give a couple copies Away really big
reminder that I've been doing the Guardians of
the Galaxy video game giveaway recently so be
sure to check my Marvel videos for the past week
or so to see if you were named as a winner during
those videos there's a bunch of stuff that I'm
working on I'll try to post all those videos as
quickly as possible everyone click here for my
full Guardians of the Galaxy 3 breakdown Easter
eggs post credit scene and click here for my
brand new Captain America 4 First Look video
and teaser thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!